the aftermath of the shootings in
Orlando everyone has had their own ideas
on the root of the problem and it will
not surprise you to hear where the worst
of those ideas came from I've been
talking about it for a long time and
I've been saying it's going to happen we
are taking in thousands of people into
our country we have no idea where they
come from we have no idea who the hell
they are okay there is there is a great
deal wrong with that not least the fact
that we know exactly where this shooter
came from because he was born in Queens
about eight miles from where Donald
Trump was born presumably when a racist
fairy brought a butternut-squash to life
now for their part
Democrats chose to focus less on the
shooter and more on the weapons he used
even springing a surprise filibuster on
the floor of the Senate Democrats led by
Chris Murphy of Connecticut held the
floor for nearly 15 hours pushing for
new regulations to stop people on the
terror watch list from buying guns and
to expand background checks after nearly
15 hours Murphy said we had gotten
signals that his two measures would get
a vote wait is he absolutely sure he saw
those signals or was that a
hallucination brought on by ammonia
poisoning after holding his pee in for
15 hours to be fair though those
proposals are actually coming up for a
votes but before you get your hopes up
there may be a bit of a problem let's
not kid ourselves the Republic the
Republicans control the House of
Representatives there is never going to
be any gun control that passes that's
true
closing the gun show loophole in this
Congress is incredibly unlikely even
regulating the gun show Paul Ryan puts
on every day is pretty much a lost cause
at this point which means here we are
again after another mass shooting with
weak legislation doomed to failure and
there is clearly a disconnect between
public opinion which favors two very
degrees a number of different gun
control measures and any practical
action in Washington and it is pretty
clear what is standing between those two
things and it's the National Rifle
Association like Peter but for guns and
effect
and to be fair to be fair to the NRA
it's not surprising they take a hard
line on gun legislation they're an
advocacy group it's what they're
supposed to do what is shocking is just
how successful they've been at it just
look at the last big failed attempt at
gun control known as the manchin-toomey
amendment there were high hopes for that
partly because it didn't really do much
it just called for background checks at
gun shows and for online sales but
mainly because joe Manchin who
co-sponsored it had some credibility
regarding firearms as your senator I'll
protect our Second Amendment rights
that's why the NRA endorsed me and I'll
take dead aim at the cap and trade bill
holy that is a guy so comfortable
with guns he basically just used one as
a hole-punch his office's three-hole
punch must be terrified and
Manchin mountain did everything he could
to appease the NRA
he even inserted several of their direct
requests into his bill including
allowing firearms dealers for the first
time since 1968 to sell handguns across
state lines which is a weird provision
to put in a gun control bill it's like
letting Jose Cuervo convince you that
the seventh step in Alcoholics Anonymous
should be tequila shots but despite all
that the NRA turned on Manchin and the
bill and then punished him by running
ads like this in his home state Manchin
is working with President Obama and New
York Mayor Michael Bloomberg concerned
yes the NRI stabbed mansion in the back
although it would have been more on
brand of them to shoot him in the back
and then argue it never would have
happened if his back had had a gun and
the thing is whenever any potential
regulation comes up the pushback is
always the same and there's just no
evidence that these gun laws would
prevent these students there is at least
an absence of certain proof as to the
efficacy of gun ownership laws in the
past to think that somehow gun control
is or increased gun control C is the
answer in my view that would have to be
proved oh yes it's the old I'm not doing
anything until you can prove it
arguments the same argument favored by
climate change deniers and fathers of
the baby on Maury happy Father's Day and
that brings us the point is that brings
us to perhaps the most ingenious and
insidious NRA tactic because they don't
just manage to block legislation
concerning guns they've managed to block
information concerning them too for
instance one of the major funders of
academic research the Centers for
Disease Control has been hamstrung in
studying how best to prevent gun
violence for the last 20 years in 1996
the NRA successfully lobbied Congress to
put this restriction into the CDC's
budget none of the funds made available
may be used to advocate or promote gun
control now the CDC was already banned
from advocating for gun control laws or
indeed any form of legislation but the
1996 Dickey amendment named after both
its sponsor Jay Dickey and after the
fact it was an extremely Dickey thing to
do had a chilling effect on the CDC
funding any gun research at all CDC
funding into gun violence research has
plummeted 96% since 1996 to just
$100,000 of last year's five point six
billion dollar CDC budget the only other
things that have dropped 96% in the last
two decades are like Oh searches and
tickle-me-elmo related stampedes
and it's not just the CDC struggling to
collect reliable gun related information
for decades the NRA of successfully
lobbied to prevent the ATF from having a
database that is electronically
searchable by name when tracing the
origins of firearms so for instance this
is what they have to do with documents
from gun shops that have gone out of
business workers here are left with an
antiquated system to trace 350,000 guns
a year requiring them to review by hand
tons of paper records and 500 million
entries on microfilm many of the records
are barely legible so for example these
are records that we received as a result
of Hurricane Katrina we're too dry these
out in the parking lot that is clearly
absurd because that does not look like a
present-day record of gun ownership it
looks like the manifesto from a Spanish
galleon that sank in 1610 so how the
has the NRA managed to accomplish
all of this because the truth is they're
not that large an organization they
claim they have a membership of around 5
million but that is 3 million fewer
members than Planet Fitness and the
members of Planet Fitness have almost no
power but most of them don't even have
the power to actually go to Planet
Fitness and that is true that is true
while in January that place is nothing
more than a storage facility for great
the colored exercise bikes and while the
NRA does spend a lot of money lobbying
they are frequently outspent by even the
N AR or National Association of Realtors
a group of wily bastards who've somehow
convinced all of us we need to live
indoors like a bunch of nerds but the
real power of the NRA is in its members
who are highly motivated and can be
mobilized quickly just look at the
website of the NRA s political action
committee you will find alerts for
practically every piece of legislation
around the country and not just write
your Congressman alerts alerts like the
following bills are scheduled to be
heard on June 14th at 9:00 a.m. in room
one to six of the state capital because
they know their members often show
up and one of the reasons they're able
to rally their base so effectively is
they have an appealingly simple message
it's all about a single issue there's no
four-point plan that they have to defend
and I would point out they only have to
say no so they're not for anything
they're against something a single issue
one word no exactly it's a lot easier to
drum up support when you're just flatly
against something there is a reason that
TLC insisted upon no scrubs and not the
implementation of a national registry of
potential scrubs aka Buster's that would
scream the scrub like tendencies or
affiliations with known scrubs they knew
no scrubs is a lot catchy oh and the
truth about politics is it's about
showing up remember the manchin-toomey
amendment what a national poll at that
time found that 88% of people supported
universal background checks and yet
Manchin's office maintains that of the
calls it received they ran two hundred
to one in opposition to the bill and
that is why it is important to actually
call your Congressman you can't just hit
them up on Twitter or Facebook because
you won't get a personal response or
even worse you'll get a very personal
response indeed put it away Carlos put
it away and remember remember the Dickey
amendment which has effectively kept the
CDC from studying gun violence
it is now opposed by both the American
Medical Association and Jay Dickey the
man who sponsored it in the first place
and yet whenever a member of Congress
tries to kill it as Nita Lowey did last
summer this is how it goes
let's support research to prevent gun
violence protect our communities and
save lives thank you the question is on
the LOI amendment all in favor say aye
all opposed say no no seem to have it
the amendment is not agreed to
it's it's like watching a committee of
dear voting against investigating the
effects of oncoming cars let's stand
still I like our chances and those
headlights are shiny and if you're
thinking well I'm sure after Orlando if
someone tries that they'll succeed
because we're all paying attention now
well here's the thing about that
representative Tony Cardenas
tried to overturn it again just this
Wednesday with an amendment to a mental
health bill and this was the result
those in favor will say aye all those
opposed say no opinion chair the noes
have it
are you kidding me that happened
four days ago and I'm guessing that
you're hearing about it for the first
time now to be honest we felt only found
out about it yesterday and we've been
working on this story all week and look
the Dickey amendment is emblematic of a
chokehold the NRA has over even basic
gun data and it should obviously be
overturned but the hard truth is NRA
members seem to care more consistently
about preventing gun control than most
of us do about passing it because while
you might be focused on gun control
right now
they will focused on it two weeks before
Orlando and they'll still be focused on
it two weeks from now so this is where I
would usually say call your senator and
representative and tell them you want to
repeal the Dickey amendment and you
should absolutely do that if you want to
but you are going to need to do more
than that you're gonna need to call them
again and remind them to repeal it then
call them on their birthday and say
happy birthday and also get rid of the
Dickey amendment call them on Arbor Day
and say happy Arbor Day whatever that is
by the way what's going on with that
Dickey amendment call them on days where
there wasn't a mass shooting and I know
those days are getting fewer and farther
between and say hey it's me again what
the up with the Dickey amendment
because repealing it is not asking much
it's not gun control it's enabling us to
have an informed conversation about what
that could look like and if a when a
proposal you like is on the table you're
going to have to make all those calls
again because remember it doesn't take
much to outnumber the NRA Planet Fitness
men
outnumber them but it is time for us to
learn what those members haven't if you
want to see serious changes you actually
have to show up every day